[Music]
hello brothers and sisters and our
beloved Secrets unsealed Su TV family
thank you for joining us for I'd like to
know our Bible question and answer
program where we have the privilege of
answering your questions from the word
of God I'm in the presence of two
distinguished fellow Travelers on the
road to to Glory uh Pastor Steven bore
the founder and president of our
ministry Pastor good to have you here
it's always good to work with you and a
special privilege of working with Pastor
Miranda indeed a a a new old friend or a
new old face shall we say this is Pastor
Daniel Miranda who worked many many
years here and is now the pastor of the
arosi and Sanger churches you branched
out and uh it's good to have you come
back and look in on us every now and
again thank you it's so good to be with
good friends uh Pastor C Murray and
Pastor Stephen bore and I do not only
enjoy the questions but I enjoy your
comments as well I learn a or learn a
lot from them well praise the lord we
learn from each other uh in one of the
programs just just passed Pastor Bor
gave me a new vision of some things that
I thought I knew a little bit now I know
a little bit more and that this this is
what makes this program so much fun uh
and if you want to be part of the fund
we encourage you to write us at tvom
tv.org that's TVM tv.org we promise to
get to your questions just as soon as we
can uh the pile is rather impressive so
we may not get to it the first week the
second week after you send them in but
we will get to them and we'll answer
them from the word of God if we can find
an answer in the word of God we will
find it and give it to you Pastor would
you open us up in with prayer and then
we'll launch out into our questions
let's pray Heavenly Father we come
before your awesome Presence at this
time and we want to ask you for wisdom
as we answer these questions you know
your people have sent them with the hope
to find answers straight from the Bible
so we don't want to give our own
opinions we only want to State what the
Bible says so help us give the right
answer and may these answers be a
blessing to all of those who listen in
the name of Jesus we pray amen amen amen
since we don't get to see so often we're
going to work you man would you read
this first question which comes to us
from Brian in cbera C canbera Australia
yes so the question has to do with
Isaiah 58:13 I'm going to read the whole
context uh he says that he's a member of
an SDA Church there in Australia and he
doesn't attend church very often because
he feels that the Three Angels messages
are not being preached or the spirit of
Prophecy is not being quoted and for
that reason
he goes to the nearest natural reserve
and takes takes pictures of God's
creation instead of going to church so
based on that his question is walking in
the nature reserve and seeing what God
has created and taking photos is this
breaking the Sabbath because the Bible
says in Isaiah
58:13 that we should not do our own
pleasure on God's holy day so that is a
question spending time in nature and
doing our own pleasure
is um breaking the
Sabbath if I can just
mention that um this is becoming more
and more frequent where people write and
uh say that they really cannot uh find a
church where the distinctive message of
the Adventist Church is being proclaimed
blamed um and the tendency is always to
say you know because I'm not hearing uh
the three Angel's message and uh
doctrines related to that that uh I'm
not going to attend church anymore so
maybe we need to address that particular
Point not only you know what they're
doing in place of attending church but
whether uh what they can do if they're
going to a church where they don't
they're not getting anything out of the
church mhm MH MH yes yes I agree and and
I have a comment on that you know I I
really I really understand my brother's
concern about seeing wanting to see a
more solid Doctrine BR Bri from our
pulpits and here are some suggestions
that I would personally give uh number
one if you don't feel comfortable at
your home Church try to find another
church where you find more you you find
yourself more comfortable uh maybe is in
a in the radios of where you live
so try to find another church if still
you don't find the church you're looking
for um don't don't absent yourself and
your family from their church for too
long or too often because even though we
don't find exactly what we are looking
for let's think about the church not
only a place to receive but also a place
to give and and you can be an influence
within your church but in order for you
to be an influence to those other church
members that have not been exposed to
the Three Angels messages then you need
to apply Christ method also to church
members you got to mingle with them
sometimes we think that Christ method
alone is only for non-believers but it
also works for church members true so if
you want to be an influence in your
church H go there without a jge ofmental
spirit try to mingle with the Brethren
uh share the pols with them launch
activities I know that you might perhaps
feel out of place but I am sure that God
is going to give you
opportunities to make friends with some
church members and you should be able to
find opportunity also to share about our
distinctive truths um and and I can
quote from Hebrews chapter 10 verse 25
verse 25 you have it there yeah I do
okay go ahead Pastor actually 24 and 25
24 and 25 MH U Pastor you have it there
I've got it
uhhuh uh and let us
consider one another in order to stir up
love and good
works not forsaking the assembling of
ourselves together as is the manner of
some but exhorting one another and so
much the more as you see the day
approaching and the day of course refers
to the second coming of Christ yes
there's so much in that's couched in
that in that verse one it's not only we
don't always go to only go to church to
consume we go to put in yes you know a
worship is not just a a a a consuming
experience it's not just what you get
out of church you got to put some stuff
in that's right so if if you're not
getting all you desire then put some
stuff in put some some things in and um
you know going to Nature is not bad but
it's not enough it's not enough there's
a reason Ellen White says uh in in
discussing the the Happ was being sent
two by two why they put 2 by two because
when you're by yourself when you're
alone you can stray
you can you can go off doctrinally you
can become discouraged you can become
depressed but if you're in a group it's
harder for that um first John 1:7 uh if
you walk in the light as he is in the
light one of the things we have is
fellowship and the blood of Christ
cleanses us from from all sin so we need
Fellowship it's an integral part of the
worship experience you can read your
Bible by yourself in your bedroom in
your bed alone but it's not the same as
coming together and worshiping one with
there is a Synergy that comes from
corporate worship that you cannot get in
your bed by yourself and alone yes and
that's
exactly what Hebrews chapter 10 says MH
it says and let us consider one another
another in order to stir up love and
good works so in other words uh a church
is not only about receiving church is
fellowshipping amen uh because if if it
was just a matter of uh of the you know
hearing truth you can stay home and you
can read your Bible yeah right you can
read the spirit of Prophecy uh but I
think we need to address uh uh something
that this uh individual that Brian
brings up he's asking if going to the
nature reserve and seeing what God has
created and taking photos is this
breaking the Sabbath and I believe the
answer to that question is no it's not
breaking the Sabbath
and I want to read a couple of
statements from Ellen White they're from
the same page of Patriarchs and Prophets
God saw that a Sabbath was essential for
men even in Paradise he needed to lay
aside his own interests and Pursuits for
one day of the seven and here comes the
reason that he might more fully
contemplate The Works of God and
meditate upon his power and goodness he
needed a Sabbath to remind him more
vividly of God
and to awaken gratitude because all that
he enjoyed and possessed came from the
beneficent hand of the Creator and on
the same page God designs that the
Sabbath shall direct the minds of men to
the
contemplation of his created Works yes
nature speaks to their senses declaring
that there is a living God the Creator
the supreme ruler of all the heavens
declare the glory of God in the
firmament showeth his handiwork
day onto Day utth speech and night onto
night showeth knowledge the beauty that
clothes the Earth is a token of God's
love we may behold it in the Everlasting
Hills in the lofty trees in the opening
Buds and the delicate flowers all speak
to us of God the Sabbath is ever
pointing to him who made them all bids
men to open the Great Book of Nature and
Trace therein the wisdom the power and
the love of the Creator so uh the
Sabbath is all about being in contact
with nature amen but the question is
what is the
motivation for going to the nature
reserve on Sabbath is the motivation
because you want to focus on the
greatness of
God or is the motivation because because
it uh maybe I shouldn't use this term
but it turns you on you know the the
bottom line is that the purpose of going
in the midst of nature is because you
want to see and understand the the
greatness and the power and the
awesomeness of God yeah if that's your
focus you're not breaking the Sabbath no
because you're bringing honor and glory
to God right particularly if you're if
you're trying to go away from Bad Church
um that may be the and that's why I said
it it's not bad but it's not enough uh
the the the Church Father Columba always
felt St Patrick's predecessor in Ireland
always felt that it was better to study
the word of God with his fellows outside
he didn't like a roof over said he
wanted always to be outside uh that's
how he felt they were closer to God so
it's really why you do certain things uh
and how you do them Dan you want to add
anything yes and you know there there is
a balance between between spending time
in nature and going to church some
Churches and Len also has quotes about
this you have programs all day right in
the church all day and and you really
you really don't get this time to spend
time in nature so there should be a
balance I want to add something else in
regards to doing our own pleasure in
Isaiah chap
58:3 what does that mean because I enjoy
eating and I eat on the Sabbath you know
and and I enjoy some people enjoy
singing some people enjoy playing their
instruments and they do that on the
Sabbath and that's that's their pleasure
yes so are we when the Bible says we
should not do our own pleasure what is
that pleasure that this is talking about
see Isaiah 58 gives us the context so I
read first verse 13
if you turn away your food from the
Sabbath from doing your own pleasure on
my holy day and call the Sabbath a
delight the holy of the Lord honorable
and shall honor him not doing your own
ways not finding your own pleasure not
speaking your own words that same word
is used in verse three the same chapter
and here it tells us what that own
pleasure is why have we fasted they say
and you have not seen why have we
Afflicted our souls and you take no
notice this in fact in the day of your
fast this was a you know a a ceremonial
Sabbath a day of atonement in the day of
your fast you find pleasure and exploit
all your labors indeed verse four for
indeed you fast for strife and debate
and to strike with the fist of
wickedness you will not fast as you do
this day to make your voice Heard On
High what was the problem with the
fasting that they had here it was a very
self center right fasting so the
pleasure that this is talking about is a
self-centered pleasure correct they were
not looking out for the needs of others
they were looking out for their own
needs and in doing so they were finding
their own pleasure so it is their
innocent Pleasures that are not wrong on
the Sabbath day like the ones we just
mentioned and some others so this will
give us a little bit of context of how
to understand that verse but but you
know even playing your instrument on
Sabbath to bring attention to yourself
right it can is breaking the Sabbath
breaking the Sabbath yeah but if you're
playing your instrument to the glory of
God it's a different story everything we
do on Sabbath has to be to the glory of
God Amen and you know the Apostle Paul
of course was right when he when he said
uh whether you eat or drink or whatever
you do and that includes Sabbath keeping
that's right do all to the glory of God
Amen yes so so there are many things on
Sabbath that we might do that bring
pleasure to us but really even eating is
to the glory of God because when we're
eating what do we do we pray we say
thank you Lord for providing this
delicious food that I'm going to enjoy
today so once again it's focused on God
anything on Sabbath that is not focused
on God is is not is doing our
will delighting in ourselves instead of
delighting in the Lord and you can take
almost any activity to the nth degree
and too far if you're lugging around a
lot of photo equipment and cameras and
tripods and all that kind of stuff you
know you take your camera or you take
your phone and you take some pictures no
problem but if you're going to turn this
thing into a production you may be
stepping a little far uh as far as
keeping the saet is concerned so you
want to be now you're into
meding so with that we'll go on to our
next
question this comes from Peter oh Pap
New Guinea uh Peter N Hallelujah yeah
from PNG
um um I have a question regarding John
4:24 so let's let's find John
4:24 uh God is spirit and those who
worship Him must Worship in spirit and
in truth he's quoting the text as per
this text what does it mean to Worship
in spirit and Truth as worship would be
an issue of Allegiance in these last
days that is certainly true so let's
walk our way through and T digest what
is being said spirit and in truth what
is spirit and in
truth the easier one of course is
truth yeah that's because you you need
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth Jesus is the truth so if
you're preaching the true Gospel of
Jesus you need to preach the truth all
that is truth and everything that truth
encompasses uh about the word of God you
want to add to that it would be good if
we can read the context of of what Jesus
said about worship shiing God in the
spirit and truth it begins in verse 21
mhm of John chapter 4 and I'm reading
from the new King James version and
Jesus said to the woman he said to
Heroman believe me the hour is coming
when you will neither on these Mountain
nor in Jerusalem worship the father and
this is after the question when she
asked that where is the right place of
worship either Jerusalem yeah or this
mountain she is really trying to move
the heat away from herself just trying
to get out from under Christ probing
questions that's right and then verse 22
you worship what you do not know we
worship what we know for salvation is of
the Jews so the question was a doctrinal
question where should we worship it was
a a doctrinal question but the hour is
coming where Jesus says and now is when
the true worshipers will worship the
father in spirit and in truth for the
father seeking such to worship him God
spirit and those who worship Him must
Worship in spirit and truth so she was
asking for the TR truth about worship
but Jesus adds it is not enough the
truth about worship you also need to
worship God in spirit and in
truth worship is an all-encompassing
thing per Revelation 14 worship includes
who we worship why we worship when we
worship how we worship all is included
in correct worship of of the Lord you
know the bottom line is I I've been to
some worship
Services where you can ice skate down
the center
aisle figuratively
speaking and yet these churches they
uphold the truth I mean they you hear
good sermons on the Sabbath on the state
of the dead and all these things you
know they use the spirit of Prophecy but
there's no Spirit there yes there's no
enthusiasm there there's no personal
involvement with the Lord MH uh it's not
an exciting experience for them now the
opposite is to for people to be dancing
in the aisles and you know like happens
in in you know using different kinds of
contemporary music and everything and
just having a real good time that's the
Other Extreme yes so I think what what
Jesus is saying is that yes we should we
should have a worship service that is
centered in
truth but which really uh gets us
emotion Ally involved with the Lord and
excited about what's happening in the
worship service amen and amen amen you
want to add to that no I think uh that
answers the question okay I just want to
add one little thing because I am and I
must admit a sermon bigot um I like to
hear truth but I like my sermons with a
little Cayenne you know I don't want
person just to get up and just talk I
want to see that it's coming out of you
but through you Len y says this there is
too much formality in our religious
services and as much as she talks about
going off the to the left she talks more
about going off to the right um the Lord
would have his ministers to preach the
word energized by his Spirit and the
people uh who hear should not sit in
drowsy indifference I like an amen you
know I like to hear the the pag is
rustling rustling I I I have sat where a
person preached his whole sermon from
his phone you know from his his cell
phone I like to see word of God that's
that's just amen amen um and or stare
vacantly about making no response to
what is said the impression that is thus
given to the unbeliever is anything but
favorable to the religion of Christ
these dull careless professed Christians
are not destitute of ambition and Zeal
um when engaged in worldly business but
things of Eternal importance do not move
them deeply the voice of God uh through
his messagers may be a pleasant song but
its sacred warnings reproofs and
encouragements are left unheeded and she
talks about Israel when the Arc of the
Covenant was brought in there was
dancing there was leaping there was a
response it was not Dull formal dry
worship and our services ought not be
dull formal dry services and praise God
you are not you are not Dull formal dry
preachers uh i' I've seen the veins pop
it on your neck in your firstand red as
you get into the message and that's what
I like to see that's that's just me I
once had an Evangelistic Series in
Lovington New Mexico I was the
ministerial director and evangelist for
the Texico conference uh for about 4 and
A2 years and this Lovington New Mexico
is just a little town probably about
four or 5,000 population and I had this
elderly couple come to my meetings and
after I preached on the Sabbath uh they
they came on a regular basis after I
preached on the Sabbath I always like to
go visit everyone who filled out the
card and said that they understood the
message and so I went to their home and
um I said you know what did you think
about the message last night and the
lady says there's no doubt whatsoever
that uh the Bible teaches that we're
supposed to keep the seventh day Sabbath
uh you know we we were impressed we we
didn't know that and so I looked at her
and I said uh well I'm glad that you
understood the message uh so I hope that
we're going to see you in in church on
Saturday you know she looked at me and
she said
um
well uh we don't really have to keep the
Sabbath and I looked at her and said um
you you don't feel like you have to keep
the Sabbath she says no we've got the
holy
spirit so so that that kind of
illustrates this verse you know that
because she belonged to a Pentecostal
church and they jump in the aisles and
they say hallelujah and praise the Lord
they have a real emotional experience I
had another experience a young man when
I came to Fresno Central Church I won't
mention his name I went through a full
series of Bible studies with him and
with his wife actually went through two
series of Bible studies and he says you
know what I like about the Seventh Day
Adventist Church he says he by the way
he hasn't gotten baptized and this has
been 30 years uh he said you know what I
like about the Seventh Day Adventist
Church he says you know I belong to the
Pentecostal church and I go to the
Pentecostal church and we get all
excited and we say hallelujah and praise
the Lord and he says and then and then I
leave church and a half an hour there's
afterwards there's nothing
left all the emotion is gone says what I
like about your church is that when I
hear a sermon I learn
truth and this individual his wife is an
Adventist and he communicates with me
now and then uh but he hasn't he
believes the truth all the truth of the
Adventist Church but he has not actually
gotten baptized wow but the reason I
tell this story is because he caught the
idea that in the Seventh Adventist
Church he's going to hear the truth
where he's at there's he doesn't attend
the Pentecostal church anymore he says
there's a lot of emotion in everything
but there's no truth there yeah and so
and so I think that when uh Jesus said
in spirit and Truth he's talking about
yes uh worshiping in truth in terms of
what the Bible teaches but at the same
time having uh your emotions involved in
in the experience yes yes praise the
Lord worship that is rational but at the
same time emotional right amen and amen
amen and amen well our time has slipped
away uh I remember preaching in New
Zealand and uh no response on the
congregation whatsoever total and at the
door they they told me how they love the
sermon but I said you didn't respond
they said we would never talk back to
you during the sermon that's that's rude
we would we would do that so there is
some cultural context to be to be had
and to be understood but uh spirit and
truth you need them both for a growing
church and a growing Christian it's the
same in Argentina yeah I spoke to 4,000
people at uh the university I couldn't
get an an amen
edgewise God bless you we'll see you
again soon bye-bye God bless
[Music]